hey folks just a short kind of
out-of-the-ordinary video for you today
a friend of mine cam recently got a math
tattoo it's not something I'd recommend
but he told his team at work that if
they reached a certain stretch goal it's
something that he'd do and well the
incentive worked Cam's initials are CSC
which happens to be the shorthand for
the cosecant function in trigonometry so
what he decided to do is make his tattoo
a certain geometric representation of
what that function means it's kind of
like a wordless signature written in
pure math it got me thinking though
about why on earth we teach students
about the trigonometric functions
cosecant secant and cotangent and it
occurred to me that there's something
kind of poetic about this particular
tattoo just as tattoos are artificially
painted on but become permanent as if
they were a core part of the recipients
flesh the fact that the cosecant is a
named function is kind of an artificial
construct on math
trigonometry could just as well have
existed intact without the cosecant ever
being named but because it was it has
this strange and artificial permanence
in our conventions and to some extent in
our education system in other words the
cosecant is not just a tattoo on cams
chest it's a tattoo on math itself
something which seemed reasonable and
even worthy of immortality at its
inception but which doesn't necessarily
hold up as time goes on here let me
actually show you all a picture of the
tattoo that he chose because not a lot
of people know that geometric
representation of the cosecant
whenever you have an angle typically
represented with the Greek letter theta
it's common in trigonometry to relate it
to a corresponding point on the unit
circle the circle with the radius one
centered at the origin in the xy-plane
most trigonometry students learn that
the distance between this point here on
the circle and the x-axis is the sine of
the angle and the distance between that
point and the y-axis is the cosine of
the angle and these links give a really
wonderful understanding for what cosine
and sine are all about people might
learn that the tangent of an angle is
sine divided by cosine and that the
cotangent is the other way around cosine
divided by sine but relatively few
learned that there's also a nice
geometric interpretation for each of
those quantities if you draw a line
tangent to the circle at this point the
distance from that point to the x axis
along that tangent is well the tangent
of the angle and the distance along that
line to the point where it hits the
y-axis well that's the cotangent of the
angle again this gives a really
intuitive feel for what those quantities
mean you kind of imagine tweaking that
theta and seeing when cotangent gets
smaller when tangent gets larger and
it's a good gut check for any students
working with them
likewise secant which is defined as 1
divided by the cosine and cosecant which
is defined as 1 divided by the sine of
theta each have their own places on this
diagram if you look at that point where
this tangent line crosses the x-axis the
distance from that point to the origin
is the secant of the angle that is 1
divided by the cosine likewise the
distance between where this tangent line
crosses the y axis and the origin is the
cosecant of the angle that is 1 divided
by the sine if you're wondering why on
earth that's true notice that we have
two similar right triangles here one
small one inside the circle and this
larger triangle whose hypotenuse is
resting on the y-axis
I'll leave it to you to check that that
interior angle up at the tip there is
theta the angle that we originally
started with over inside the circle now
for each one of those triangles I want
you to think about the ratio of the
length of the side opposite theta to the
length of the hypotenuse for the small
triangle the length of the opposite side
is sine of theta and the hypotenuse is
that radius the one that we define to
have length one
so the ratio is just sine of theta
divided by one now when we look at the
larger triangle the side opposite theta
is that radial line of length 1 and the
hypotenuse is now this length on the
y-axis
the one that I'm claiming is the
cosecant if you take the reciprocal of
each side here you see that this matches
up with the fact that the cosecant of
theta is 1 divided by sine kind of cool
right it's also kind of nice that sine
tangent and secant all correspond to
lengths of lines that somehow go to the
x-axis and then the corresponding cosine
cotangent and cosecant are all then
lengths of lines going to the
corresponding spots on the y-axis and on
a diagram like this it might be pleasing
that all six of these are separately
named functions but in any practical use
of trigonometry you can get by just
using sine cosine and tangent in fact if
you really want it you could define all
six of these in terms of sine alone but
the sort of things the cosine and
tangent correspond to come up frequently
enough that it's more convenient to give
them their own names but cosecant secant
and cotangent never really come up in
problem solving in a way that's not just
as convenient to write in terms of sine
cosine and tangent at that point it's
really just adding more words for
students to learn with not that much
added utility and if anything if you
only introduced secant as one over
cosine and cosecant as one over sine the
mismatch of this Co prefix is probably
just an added point of confusion in a
class that's prone enough to confusion
for many of its students
the reason that all six of these
functions have separate names by the way
is that before computers and calculators
if you were doing trigonometry maybe cuz
you're a sailor or an astronomer or some
kind of engineer you would find the
values for these functions using large
charts that just recorded known
input-output pairs and when you can't
easily plug in something like 1 divided
by the sine of 30 degrees into a
calculator it might actually make sense
to have a dedicated column to this value
with a dedicated name and if you have a
diagram like this one in mind when
you're taking measurements with sine
tangent and secant having nicely
mirrored meanings to cosine cotangent
and cosecant calling this cosecant
instead of 1 divided by sine might
actually make some sense and it might
actually make it easier to remember what
it means geometrically but times have
changed and most use cases for trig just
don't involve charts of values and
diagrams like this hence the cosecant
and it's brothers are tattoos on math
ideas whose permanence in our
conventions is our own doing not the
result of nature itself and in general I
actually think this is a good lesson for
any student learning a new piece of math
at whatever level you just got to take a
moment and ask yourself whether what
you're learning is core to the flesh of
math itself and to nature itself or if
what you're looking at is actually just
inked on to the subject and could just
as easily have been inked on in some
completely other way